I mean this California you got beautiful
weather you got beautiful women you got
lowriders and then you got burgers man
[Music]
whether at restaurants or drive-throughs
burger icons are everywhere in LA but
you can't talk about LA's burger culture
without talking about the backyard
burger
no one epitomizes the tradition quite
like the Chicano lowrider clubs of East
LA where DIY home grilled burgers are a
focal point for the community today
we're in my hood Pico Rivera and we're
going to link up with some of the
members of together car club to make the
ultimate backyard burger
my name is Chris I go by creaks man eg
everybody calls me turtle here my name
is Eddie I've been a spell for 40 years
oh I got an 81 cutlass supreme I
dedicate to my sister she passed away of
cancer burgers
low-riding it's like ability how high
you want a hollow you want we got prom
like we got lettuce we got paint as we
got tomato and I'm not gonna be here
just five years now I'm gonna be here
for life you know I'm gonna represent
all day every day right here in people
there man
when I was a kid like I used to just
hang out at the in and out burger right
here on Whittier Boulevard or sometime
that taught me is right and I would see
the cars come up and it's just like the
most amazing thing to see so how did
this whole thing start low ready started
back in the 50s guys wanted to show off
their cars let's say what fix them up
with rims you know drop them down make
them look classy
cruising I mean where's low and slow
yeah man so everyone can see right if
you drive too fast they don't see you
the slower you go the more you know how
do you get him set together car club but
we had standards your car had to be what
they call flyable this is an example of
flyable car clean white walls armor-all
tires no spots on the chrome no spots on
the windows paint job had to be
immaculate we also had rules and if you
didn't comply with the rules we had a
paddle okay I'm and I'm gonna go ahead
and have you it's an enforcement thing
to let you know that listen we need to
have a set of standards that can follow
and you take them serious and we take
them very soon respect everyone thinks I
call it swell like gangs and stuff like
that but it's really the complete
opposites about family right legs right
you're gonna see it in gangster rap
you're gonna see it in R&B right it's
just the love of the game they should I
love the car however when you're
portraying our our culture into a
negative scene which everybody knows
we're all front we're all from a scene
like that right but what we do now is
not not to destroy our communities but
to raise up and build up those
communities Yeah right just for kids put
them to college on this car color for
these people here all right I'm all
about brothers here we show positive
move whether you're from our
neighborhood or not doesn't matter we
love everybody in general come in here
you change right you become a really
responsible person because you know what
that car you have is your pride and the
pack your flight is your pride and
that's your heart as a Filipino guy I
grew up in a predominantly Latino
neighborhood all my friends were you
know either Mexican or or El Salvadorian
you know I've always been like oh you
know you're the Chino right I like and
it's like you know what no I'm actually
from here you know I mean like I you
know I I embrace this culture that's why
I wanted to bring it back I wanted to
show people you know what real burger
culture is in Southern California
because burgers and
fighters Sunday afternoon doesn't matter
where you're from everybody's walking
into this culture right it's getting
she's back
all right along with every place yeah
well usually after you know we go
cruising or hanging out somewhere we
come back to the lowrider house in grill
what we usually grow the most of would
be asada and burgers burgers always come
hand-in-hand to what we do I would like
to show my appreciation to you guys and
make you guys a burger that I feel is
inspired by growing up in Pico Rivera
well let you see our car you let us see
that burger on a Sunday afternoon making
burgers in the backyard having a cold
one on your other hand
that's heaven to me of course that's why
we better than there that's why we're
here today I wanted to make a burger
that's inspired by the east side of Los
Angeles this is like grill master 101
right here right this is a weber girls
like classic has to be charcoal never
propane if you just smoke flavor yeah
it's more flavor right yeah definitely
so what I do is I throw all my hot coals
all on one side so if you hold your hand
like right here this is like a like
putting your burger on a frying pan it's
super hot okay and then this is like
putting your burger in the oven because
there's no direct heat hitting gotcha
right more like a slow cook now the
secret to a good burger is like having
that nice crust on the outside but still
nice and juicy on the inside of course I
like making patties a little bit bigger
than the bun so that it has room to
shrink here is just carne asada
seasoning and the reason why we do this
is because usually you're cooking carne
asada first right so then all the
flavoring gets on the grill okay
and then you throw up you throw a burger
on after that you smell it smells like
it and you could get never be too stingy
messy yeah yeah that smells real good so
you throw this on seasoning down and
then you hit it again so if you want
like a medium-rare burger that this size
you're probably doing minute and a half
on each side and then you switch it over
here and let it cook through this is
like 80% lean 20% fat so the fat is
dropping onto the coals so that smoke
that it creates is the flavor Oh a lot
of people they they put the spatula and
press down on a shot and never do that
yeah you don't that's right that's all
that all the good stuff is leaving the
burger when you want to check for
doneness like I don't know how you guys
like your burgers I like mine a little
bit medium rule when you have steaks you
feel them on the top
here but when you do burgers because
it's ground meat you have to do it them
from the side ah ok so when it bounces
back like that that's about medium I'm
using Jack cheese I feel like that's
like the the cheese of Champions out
here yeah when I was a kid we used to go
to this place in Pico called guacamoles
ok and their burgers paddock walking it
so you know that's always a highlight
why not right not ya know this is this
cheese is like barely melted through
that's just the way I like it
I'm kind of nervous to give us you guys
I heard you're like the rib guy the
grill master these are my pork baby
backs Alvin award-winning pork ribs I
hear well I've won a few awards Oh mom
smoky sweet it's super tender you're not
hiding the flavor of the pork that's
fantastic
that was an amazing rib but since you
guys are in the customizing culture
I want to customize this burger and grab
some of your rib meat what are we doing
is he's doing boy taught it on top of
this burger real mastering the grill
master we'll call this up together in
Pico a salute to that try it out that is
really good yeah good I'll let you know
when I finish all right cool yeah we
passed the grill masters test it's
Sunday
let's stop talking to this let me tell
you you did a really good job thank you
for being there back to people some home
cooked Mitchell right here in the front
lawn of our lowrider house can't go
wrong SLA first show baby
I'm out until the next police show I'm
out on the streets looking for something
to eat like I never tasted a burger that
good I'm not lying to you honestly it's
you know Matt sub guys have a kai-lan
for the burger show thank you for
watching hit the like button hit the
subscribe button if not for me for the
burgers please and thank you